et on évoque cette visite avec gilbert
sinoué écrivain historien du monde arabe
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france emmanuel macron un défendant
selon ses mots une ouverture
démocratique et une société civile
dynamique et active
il était très attendu sur cette question
des droits de l'homme on l'a entendu à
l'instant il a également déclaré qu'il
ne conditionnerait pas la coopération en
matière de défense comme en matière
économique à ces désaccords que vous
inspirent ces propos écoutez je pense
que média macro ont répondu la manière
la plus sage qui soit imposée elle
démocratie ap il me semble faire atat
porter atteinte à sa souveraineté
je crois que les peuples sont assez
grands pour s'auto gérer eux-mêmes pour
décider s'ils veulent conserver un
gouvernement qui considèrent eux
autoritaire ou privative de liberté et
c'est au peuple égyptien lui-même de
faire le ménage il envie de le faire il
a déjà fait dans le passé on l'a vu avec
moubarak on l'a vu nancy et voilà je
pense que benzema cran a très bien réagi
et je ne vois vraiment pas l'utilité
d'imposer des sanctions l api d'autant
que ce pays est composé de cent mille
habitants et que maîtrisé cent mille
habitants ce n'est pas aussi simple que
l'on maîtrise et 60 ou 70 milles
ajoutons à cela que c'est un peuple
fragile et qu'il est pris en tenaille
entre la libye et les frères musulmans
et par conséquent je pense que on lui
impose et descend en lui imposant des
sanctions ont le feu on ne ferait que
l'affaiblir
cette visite intervient donc en pleine
remise en question des exportations
d'armes vers des pays accusés de
violations des droits humains et
l'egypte est l'un des trois principaux
clients de l'industrie de l'internement
1 tricolore
vous savez on n'est pas chez blanche
neige
vous savez parfaitement qu'on vend des
armes à des pays comme l'arabie séoudite
et à d'autres qui sont encore moins
moins respectueux des droits de l'homme
que l'egypte c'est un jeu de poker qui
se joue dans le monde la géopolitique et
et le commerce prime tous
malheureusement donc le fait que la
france vend des armes à l'egypte n'en
fait pas une exception
non il s'agit aussi pour emmanuel macron
et son homologue égyptien de débattre
des grandes crises régionales
concrètement sur quoi peut aboutir leurs
échanges aujourd'hui
écoutez je pense déjà qu'ils sont
d'accord sur deux points fondamentaux
même 3 la lutte contre le terrorisme
parce que l'egypte on en a subi les
conséquences comme la france ils sont
d'accord sur le problème libyen
puisqu'ils sont du même côté en même
temps que les émirats et je pense qu'ils
sont aussi d'accord pour essayer de
stopper l'hégémonie ou ce que
j'appellerais la folie mégalomane du
président turc
donc voilà trois points qui me semblent
s'associer à un projet futur mais ce
qu'on peut s'attendre à des déclarations
un très concrètes
il faut l'espérer
il faut l'espérer je pense qu'on l'a on
aboutira en tout cas à une o2
déclaration concrètes certainement vous
savez ce ses retrouvailles avec 6,6 le
dernier voyage je les fais avec macron
d'ailleurs en 2019 en janvier le dernier
le dernier rapport remonte à près de
près de deux ans donc s'il se retrouve
c'est sûrement parce qu'ils ont des
choses à se dire et des choses à
et des règlements à jallais pas dire des
règlements de comptes mais je suppose
que si socke sim président sicié venue à
paris c'est pour aboutir à quelque chose
de concret enfin j'imagine alors on l'a
dit cette visite d'état de deux jours a
été très critiqué par les ong est ce
qu'on peut dire effectivement
qu'aujourd'hui c'était un c'est un jeu
d'équilibriste pour emmanuel macron
entre eux finalement conforté ce
partenaire stratégique qu'est l'egypte
pour la france et cette question des
droits de l'homme
vous savez cette question des droits de
l'homme
dieu sait si je la respecte mais elle
est devenue obsessionnelle
il faut il faut il faut pas regarder les
pays avec notre propre regard
il faut regarder les pays avec leur
propre gré à l'intérieur est ce qu'on
peut imposer en france ou en angleterre
ou en europe
on peut pas nécessairement la pause et
dans certains pays on le sait il y a des
murs il ya des murailles et elles sont
pas toujours faciles à briser il faut
être patient je comprends le besoin des
ong d'amnesty international ou face à la
situation égyptienne qui n'est pas du
tout tendre avec les récalcitrants mais
je pense qu'il faut de la patience qu'il
faut du temps et sûrement pas essayer de
punir le pays qui enfreignent ces règles
on a vu ce que ça a donné avec l'irak
une catastrophe humanitaire un désastre
absolu
et finalement quand vous vous imposer
des sanctions
ce n'est pas les gouvernants qui payent
la facture c'est toujours le peuple
or le peuple égyptien est en souffrance
le peuple égyptien a faim
le peuple haïtien a besoin de nourrir 5
6 enfants et je ne pense pas du tout qu
en faisant des pressions économiques par
le biais des ong soit vraiment la
solution pour shaw peuple merci d'avoir
pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions ou gilbert sinoué
historien du monde arabe